I team Coco Jack here from bleachers I'm
on tour right now and on tour I watched
a lot of YouTube videos well I try to do
a lot of work but I end up watching a
lot of YouTube videos it's easy to get
into a hole sometimes it's serious
sometimes it's funny stuff but I've
selected five videos that I love that I
think really cover what I'm into as a
human being the first one is Kelsey
Grammer falling off the stage while
giving a speech so it's a small world
pretending I was a UN interpreter
someone eating [ __ ] and falling off a
stage can I curse yeah it's fine right
yeah let's keep going someone new eating
[ __ ] and falling off the stage is funny
what's better about this is it's Kelsey
Grammer and I don't think you knew that
you want to see Kelsey Grammer fall off
a stage until you see him fall off a
stage I don't believe that anyone should
fall off the stage or get hurt but if
there was something that you could say
that you would then deserve to fall off
a stage right after saying it it would
be the line he says which is I remember
as a small child going through it's a
small world thinking I was a UN
Ambassador next video I chose is a very
serious ones too whoo playing Baba
O'Riley at the concert for New York
which was very shortly after 9/11
[Music]
they filled the garden with firefighters
police men first responders and their
families the who goes into babble Riley
and it's like the quintessential song of
the generation of people that are in the
room
if you don't weep while watching this
then I can't help you
[Music]
[Applause]
the next video is for the other I'm in
and I think it's the only video I could
choose of myself that wouldn't lead to
me being like pompous ass because in
this video I fall off stage like Kelsey
Grammer
don't say anything before I fall off
stage I did think in my head as a young
child I remember drifting through it's a
small world thinking I was a UN
ambassador think about falling off stage
which I would love to talk to Kelsey
about a lot of things but specifically
about this is you don't know until
you're down like if you're not like I'm
falling you're just like all of a sudden
it just happened you don't think it's
like that Ellen joke about falling I'm
not trying to rip her off but like you
don't think there's blood everywhere
like I'm gonna die or contract hepatitis
you think is gonna end up on YouTube and
it did
[Applause]
the Beyonce clown is probably the most
popular YouTube video on my list but
it's still not as popular as it should
be because it's a multi-faceted video so
she's in this evil clown mask it's very
under female her killer clown from outer
space it's very much like that look
doing the single ladies dance and
they're just like oh this is very funny
and then smash I assume she's not dead
and doesn't have brain damage because I
feel like we would have heard of that
but this is the least funny funny video
another video that I love which is
similar to the Beyonce clown video is
these two girls who shot themselves who
videotaped themselves doing the risky
business scene where they slide into
frame stun and then one girl slides in
no no no no no no the other girl slides
in and eats [ __ ] and my favorite part
about this video is like you think it
would end there but there's like a
minute of two of them like oh my god
that's a good video before I say goodbye
there's one more video which is another
one that's more in the serious sort of
inspirational territory and I fell in
love with music at a very young age and
specifically live music the greatest
show on earth to me is Queen why babe
[Applause]
and Freddie Mercury is at his absolute
peak the band is at their peak and he's
just commanding the stadium it's easy to
forget what a brilliant song radio
gaagaa is I literally think it's the
greatest live performance I've ever seen
and the way it's shot and the YouTube
video of it is perfect
[Music]
thanks for hanging out with me I hope
these videos don't take you to
back-and-forth on the emotional scale
some of them will make you laugh some of
them make you cringe some of them will
make you cry but you know if we ever
meet these are things I'd love to talk
about they say white girls can you cut
that cuz I'm not gonna be I'm not gonna
be able to explain what I meant there